how's it going everyone this is
International Master Daniel wrench this
is chest comms YouTube channel and today
I am back for another opening lecture
continuing our journey to hopefully give
you a quick short video lesson on every
major mainline weapon we've already done
a lot in our chess openings playlist you
can check them out and so today right
now what I'd like to do is cover an
opening that's a personal favourite of
mine
considering that it's a it's a weapon
that I use from the black side we're
going to look at it from the white
perspective because generally when
you're trying to learn opening
principles especially for taking this
sort of bigger picture perspective it
doesn't really matter what point of view
you're looking at it from and if you're
one of these players who really
struggles looking at an opening from the
opposite side then simply work on that
instead of always having to flip the
board try to see the concepts for what
they are rather than feeling like you
need to have a bias in terms of your
your perspective toward the opening
that's just a little general piece of
advice instead of complaining about not
being able to flip the board so anyway
just kidding but let's do this the
nimzo-indian starts with one d4 it is a
Queen's pawn game and of course there
are many openings both the Queen's pawn
in the King's pawn but that's not what
we're here to talk about we're going to
get right to the news oh it's Elf 9 f 6
c4 e6 Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 the
general idea for black in the nihms win
is is a dynamic one it's a dynamic
approach what do I mean by that
well there's positions that are static
equality meaning the structure is
exactly the same generally both sides
have the same types of minor pieces
there's not really an imbalance and
they're all different types of important
philosophies and strategies for playing
static equality your static structures
that are sort of locked and then there's
dynamic games like an Enzo Indian for
example where the general idea for black
is to give up the bishop for this night
giving white the powerful bishop pair
which is indeed a weapon don't kid
yourself the bishop era as most
positions do eventually become open and
dynamic giving it up so early is always
a risk at a general level for example
the same ish a3 Bishop takes c3 B takes
c3 is a classical line of the nihms oh
where black is giving up the bishop
early and doing so willingly what does
by getting in compensation for these two
powerful bishops and potentially very
strong Center for white if you can ever
expand it black is getting the ability
to target these these doubled pawns for
the rest of the game it's a huge
positional disadvantage these are not
the type of double pawns that that are
going to undo themselves as long as
black doesn't make a sort of positional
blunder with a move like d5 letting them
on the more standard approach in the
nihms oh is to take double the pawns and
then play see five either here or even
after castles what your what you're
seeing here is a position where black is
is is locking these pawns down and after
a few more natural moves III castles
Bishop develops black develops a knight
white develops B six castles Bishop a 6
we see blacks developing plan is
actually very straightforward
he played b6 to bring the bishop here he
brought the night here in order to put
it here we're both both of these pieces
you see are now barreling down on this
weakness and the fact that he's extended
the c5 pawn has locked these guys in and
potentially prepared that the open way
for the C file if the rook comes to c8
we capture on d4 this pawn is a big time
problem
well white generally doesn't align like
this and this is something that really
highlights as I said the difference
between static and dynamic play where
where white has this horrible weakness
um but his his his compensation is is
one with the bishop pair in the center
white plays d4 you see it's a dynamic
game meaning it's roughly equal but but
both sides are playing four completely
different things black with this sort of
goal to keep the position semi closed
target White's positional weaknesses and
develop all of his pieces with those
goals in mind and my apologies for that
black is black is keeping all those
positional goals in mind but he must be
very wary of White's pieces coming
potentially toward the Kings side as the
bishop pair is a very dangerous tool if
you're trying to attack the King the
best move here for black in this line is
a move like ninety eight simply
preventing the pin with Bishop g5 and
and taking away some of the power of
this advance of e5 after which black
typically continues with f4 and there
are two ways to approach it black can
immediately play Knight a5 rook c8 at
some point maybe even consider bringing
this 90 d6 but that is usually overkill
as as white can't really depend upon
anyway and doesn't really want to
I would rather use this time to attack
the king so black can move forward with
that and intend to meet f5 with the move
f6 trying to slow down the pollen storm
or black can play the more modern and
more accurate move f5 if anybody
remembers I reviewed one of my favorite
games from the nimzo-indian Geller ooh a
ooh vay from Zurich international 1953
and highly recommended the Zurich
International 1953 book by Bronstein
but f5 is the more modern approach the
idea for black is to is to continue to
maintain an effort to keep it sort of
semi closed putting a clamp on this f4
pawn which in turn prevents real
activity from this Bishop the theory
here is dynamic though this line is
considered to be generally good for
black at the highest level these days
but I wanted to start with this line
first when giving you a general outlook
of the nihms oh I liked the imbalances
one point would be if 9 a 5 f5 just to
show you the power of the attack let's
say black just ignores White's attack
and and continues to move ahead this
will just show you the imbalance that
the white doesn't really care that much
about the queenside if he can establish
things like this f6 is a brilliant move
prying open the King here obviously pawn
takes would be pretty ugly and pretty
risky and probably pieces will continue
to come over here and in a number of
different fashions and black will find
his King in big trouble but the other
even the other move Knight takes f6
wouldn't really help at this point as I
deceive my goal of pinning I'm
threatening e5 threatening to double
your your pawns along the F file and
open up your King at the same time and
we see this these are the kind of issues
black can deal with if he if he doesn't
take the appropriate measures like
either f6 in this position before taking
the pawn as the game killer of a Zurich
international 1953 showed again you can
find that game in our in our classic
chess game suite chess games playlist
here or the more modern approach by
black which is considered the best which
is f5 back to the beginning positions of
the nihms oh I will say that the other
major way for white to play other than
going for variations that have this sort
of imbalance of the double pawns is the
classical variation of the nihms oh that
we know c2 black has several moves you
can play b6 he can play c5 you can play
d five and he can play castles it's
debatable actually which one is best but
and so instead of reviewing it a whole
bunches these video lectures are just
designed to give you sort of a general
outlook and kind of a well-considered a
kick start right into getting your
getting your knowledge of this opening
started and there are more main main
full-length featured lectures on are on
our website chess comm of course you can
go there and subscribe to that but
otherwise you can use this as just sort
of a general guideline and use other
information you can find to help you so
the Queen c2 idea is pretty clear white
it white is wasting a little bit of time
with the Queen with the with the idea of
avoiding the double pawns so let's say
after the standard move like castles
white might play a three and after chop
Alicia's chop Alicia's we have a new
kind of imbalance and imbalance position
where White has the bishop pair and
doesn't have these horrible positional
weaknesses you might think wow this
looks like the best way for white to
play but of course the disadvantage is
that you've lost some significant time
black can play several moves here
including 94 d5 b6 and even c5 all these
moves are completely playable for black
and you get a struggle where White has
the bishop pair and so a long-term
advantage if he can develop the King
side and get both bishops activated but
he's lost some time and so the dynamic
play continues from there other
variations that can occur from the
nimzo-indian after Bishop to b4 we can
also see III right away and if a3 is
played we'll have transposed is a term
used in the opening when you reach the
same position through a different move
order you can transpose into the line I
first showed you in the same --is-- or
you can see moves like Knight G to e2
here again with an idea kind of like the
classical to avoid double pawns but what
are we doing once again we're sort of
blocking our own development so even if
black plays something like d5 a3 and
retreats the bishop will see that it's a
perfectly playable position more of a
static structure where neither side has
given up too much
White's avoided the positional
weaknesses on the Queen side but has
also blocked in the development of its
King side Bishop finally another way to
play is a very standard move Knight f3
very natural developing move against e5
is the Huebner variation roman shinji
house really has some great video
lectures on that on our main site b6 is
playable to move order that I play more
like a Queen's Indian setup which is
another
opening lecture we're going to have here
for you in our chess openings play this
on YouTube very very shortly and even
castles again if a3 has played this this
is usually a mistake for white because
now White has the same position
weaknesses but the knight on f3 is not
as good as it was in the first line I
showed you you can back up and see the
video again because you'll notice that
in the other position the knight was on
e too which sort of allowed these F
pawns and E pawns to roll quickly a lot
of people don't know that small little
idiosyncrasy that typically trying to
play this way with a knight of three is
it is AB is a can be a devastating error
against an advanced player who knows
what he's doing
so instead after castles those moves
like Bishop to g5 there's also moves
like e3 here if they take here again
they can try to get that structure but
White hasn't wasted this tempo the
position is still more imbalanced and so
with that said I would say that there
are those are the main ways for white to
play with again to review y can play the
classical avoiding double pawns but
taking the risk of losing time with the
Queen you can play the same ish and the
shivery sharp classical positions where
white gets this bishop pair and big
center imbalance and dynamic
compensation from his horrible
weaknesses then there is III which is a
flexible move again you can play a move
like a3 and transpose you can play moves
like Knight G 2 you can also play moves
like Bishop b3 and then 92 I forgot to
mention after which in this position
black has options of both c5 and d5 and
you can also play the moves with Knight
f3 which sometimes has the idea of a
Bishop g5 development sometimes you play
e3 and n transpose into similar
structures you just have to avoid
playing a3 in a lot of positions as that
loss of time can be critical okay well
thanks everybody for checking out this
video lecture on chess openings playlist
on the nimzo-indian this has been Daniel
wrench with another video lecture and
we're going to see you around on shells
calm hope you enjoyed this video and
I'll see you around on chess calm